hi guys I'm back again I had another
question that relates to the cause of
coronary heart disease all right and
just realize that all the information
I'm sharing with you is just for you to
get more information to do your own
research I'm not telling you that we
have the answers to cure any diseases
anything like that just go ahead do your
own research
alright but the point is my opinion it
comes from two situations the coronary
artery is the main artery that supplies
blood to the heart muscle
okay and there's two controlling factors
over that one is adrenaline an
adrenaline has an interesting thing
because it causes constriction of the
blood vessels except for the coronary
artery in which adrenaline opens up that
vessel by vaso dilating it all the other
vessels are constricted
this one's bays are dilated giving the
heart muscle more oxygen so the muscle
can chill out and work but there's one
thing about the heart if it it lacks
oxygen it goes into a cramp and you get
a heart attack so what causes a spike of
adrenaline is stress so if you have
yours of stress you can kind of burn out
the adrenals to the point where you
don't get that function anymore and now
the valve becomes tighter and tighter
and tighter more constricting and then
we compound that with a clogged artery
or even a fibrous adhesion that's
building up because the blood vessel is
damaged and that comes from high insulin
not necessarily consuming high fats it's
the high sugars in the carbohydrates and
the wine and the juice all that converts
to cholesterol that's gonna plug up this
artery so if you combine stress with
high insulin if you're a pre-diabetic
that's even worse if that's why a lot of
diabetics have coronary heart problems
because of this because they're they're
gonna convert a lot of carbohydrate to
that cholesterol and clog these arteries
right here what's interesting if you
consume saturated fats which everyone
says to avoid but the same time cut out
the sugars you're gonna be totally fine
so it's not the fat that's clogging the
arteries it's the sugar all right that's
my opinion and I'm sticking to it
hi guys listen I want to thank you so
much for your wonderful comment
and I want to ask you if you wouldn't
mind giving me your review on Google I
put a link down below I'd really
appreciate it and thank you in advance